my name is Ben Sidman and today I've
been challenged to break down
pickpocketing in nine levels of
[Music]
complexity there are two types of
pickpocketing the criminally invasive
type that is devastating and the fun
theatrical pickpocketing I am of course
the latter option because if I was
actually stealing things on the street I
wouldn't say it on
camera as a disclaimer this is my
interpretation of the
challenge level one the table steel hey
what's your name I'm Erica hey Erica Ben
I'm just with production um did they
have you sign a release already uh no no
can you is that okay if we have you sign
it we're we're going to start filming in
just a second you can look at it you
don't have to uh you don't have to sign
it now just give it a quick look through
if you want okay um thanks level one is
all about simply hiding the steel a
thief will typically use an object as
cover this is called shade the Mark is
the person who is is about to be stolen
from otherwise known as the chump so in
this case I'm using the release as shade
on the clipboard so she looked at the
release and the moment she looked up at
me using the clipboard as cover I just
picked the phone up at that moment too I
wanted her to maintain ey contact with
me so I got a little closer to her
visual space at that point my hand went
South with her phone and I pocketed it
this is a common steal used by criminals
on the street because it is by far the
easiest to execute it requires almost no
Tech technical skill but it does rely on
distraction and some choreography hey uh
Erica yes to with all the talent anyone
who's appearing in this video we're
doing a quick selfie so smile awesome
cool and uh do you want a copy of this
photo sure sure why not well you have
one this is your phone oh yeah it is
yeah that's yours you can have that back
thank
you level two outside breast pocket hey
how's it going I'm Ben hey Ben I'm Sam
Sam nice to meet you thank you for being
here you don't know what we're doing yet
no not yet but I want you to take this
index card with your left hand and the
pen in your right hand oh can you grab
that yeah yeah thanks I'm defining
complexity in these levels based on how
difficult the steals are to accomplish
both physically but also based on the
misdirection that I have to use to
direct people's attention away from the
Steels level two is all about hiding the
motion of the steel this is also the
easiest of any of the pocket Steels
because the shade and the movement is
built directly into the moment I'm
letting the mark use his own kinetic
energy to basically do the steel for me
so I'm going to have you get ready to
write something down so first of all Sam
I want you to write down whether or not
you like my new pair of
sunglasses oh my oh my
[Music]
gosh level three the ID badge steel
what's your name Alex Alex Ben nice to
meet you Ben I uh I suppose I guess I
could have just looked down and seen
what your name was you know they say
that a good way to remember people's
names besides reading it is to like make
eye contact and then say it out loud for
level three my main goal is to hide my
intent as I'm meeting the participants
I'm lying to some of them about who I am
and what this whole video is for when I
steal badges I like to do it in two
steps typically you don't want heat on
the item that you're stealing but in
this case calling attention to it helps
hide the first move we call this
painting it red if you can't hide
something make it more obvious the
release of the badge can sometimes be
audible so I snap my fingers in the
context of the script that helps hide
the sound I'm putting the ID badge steel
at level three because it's closer to
the Natural eyeline of The Spectator it
also requires openly touching the item
that I'm stealing if I don't execute the
steel perfectly the mark could feel the
tug of the band around their neck or
hear the sound of the badge detaching
there's a lot of trip wires with this
one but another good way to remember
someone's name is to have it written
down somewhere which is why I have this
that's yours did you feel me take it no
you are you're good level four outside
jacket pocket Shelby I'm Ben hi Ben nice
to meet you nice to meet you thank you
so much for coming and being a part of
this I have a uh a deck of cards for you
actually okay I'm going to do a magic
trick amazing okay tell me out of
curiosity you can just relax um do you
have uh do you have inside jacket
pockets in this jacket uh no don't okay
that's fine don't worry about that um in
that case I'll have you just put these
in your back pocket okay and then for
the shot can we get you guys to face
our camera down there and you want us
like close together like this close you
can get okay perfect that's great pretty
close that's great level four is all
about hiding the sensation of the steel
pick pockets on the street choose
locations to work where people are
naturally shoved together so the
environment actually provides the intent
of the steel on stage I have to figure
out if someone actually has something in
this pocket so I use a technique known
as Fanning and that's just you feeling
to see if they have anything in their
pocket I actually stole This Woman's
wallet and then replaced it back in her
pocket because I didn't want to blow my
cover and I wanted to show you a second
way to execute this steel I might open
somebody's jacket to indicate to
something this provides shade it also
keeps the jacket farther away from their
body which means that the dip is much
harder to feel the second method is much
closer to what you might see a
pickpocket do on the street with people
crowded together I use the jacket as
shade and then I just very carefully
dipped in so I could make the steel
without her knowing so Shelby uh by the
way I have a confession to make okay I
know that the camera guys were
positioning us next to each other you're
actually not here to say a magic trick
at all okay this entire video has been
about pickpocketing great and tell me
Shelby does this wallet look like yours
amazing amazing are we still rolling on
that okay good level five stealing a
smartwatch so Amber uh tell me are you
familiar with tarot cards barely but
have you ever had your tarot red no no
okay have you ever had your palm red no
I don't think maybe once hold on to
those I'm going to see okay so I'm not
an expert on this but we are we're
filming a thing about reading people
that's your Lifeline right there I think
that's your love line I'm not good at
this stuff as you may see but um yeah I
think I think we can do this can I have
you uh stand up for me actually will you
stand watch your step right over there
yeah take one step this way watches are
rarely stolen outside of a performance
situation but they're very very
effective when performing in front of an
audience the physical steel is only part
of the picture in every case I have to
manage the broad attentional focus of
the person I'm performing for I begin by
establishing the context of the
situation and building Rapport and Trust
I also am conditioning The Spectator to
my touch for example I'm just putting
this silver dollar in my hand that's
like the first time that I touch her
then I touch her again same thing
happens so in her mind she gets
comfortable with that touch and so when
I do the sneaky thing she has gotten
comfortable with the touch so as I bring
her to her feet I slip my thumb in
between the two parts of the watch band
and I separate the band from the pin
once I do that I slide the watch off of
her wrist now there are a lot of trip
wires here the part of the watch that
moves the most is actually the part
that's sitting up against her skin so I
have to be mindful that that rubber
dragging on her skin isn't something
that she feels also once I open the band
the sides of the watch could hit her arm
or her body as I go south with the watch
that's why I'm using the bigger motion
of her standing up and me moving her to
cover the smaller motion of me stealing
the watch now I'm using a combination of
everything we've learned from all of the
previous levels I'm hiding the steal I'm
hiding the motion I'm hiding the intent
and I'm also hiding the sensation Bas
the camera that's perfect and then uh
I'm going to ask you a couple quick
questions starting with does this watch
look
familiar that was on my wrist level six
the traditional watch Steel uh Lauren I
am a magician and I'm going to play a
game with you where you get a chance to
win some money how does that sound yeah
good for me so I have 100 and a $2 bill
you get the $2 bill and I want you to
take it and fold it in half like that
and then fold it in half again and then
one more time into a square perfect now
uh if you wouldn't mind hold out your
hand great uh I want you to hold on to
both of those bills but turn your hand
Palm down like that that's perfect now I
can't take those out without you feeling
me do it so I'm just going to openly go
in and take one of them out okay and in
this case oh bummer in this case I got
the two but do me a favor uh with your
right hand hold on to my wrist and hold
like tightly like actually hold tightly
beautiful watch that
too because it changes what the okay to
the 100 that's so awesome look in your
hand dang dude I wanted that 100 like
any steel I have to manipulate the broad
attentional focus of the subject broad
distractions don't really work here
because the subject could look back and
catch me at any time now there are
different ways to manipulate someone's
attention you can overwhelm someone's
attention you could split someone's
attention and then of course drawing
someone's attention to one specific
thing here I'm using a combination of
all of these techniques I give the mark
two different bills to focus on now I've
Justified why I'm touching her she is
condition to my touch and I'm splitting
her attention between two different
things as I hold her wrist I execute the
first part of the steel bringing the
tail end of the watch out from under the
two Loops next the attention splitting
begins I remove one of the two bills and
ask her to look at it to do this I
illustrate by grabbing her other wrist
and at that moment I'm able to actually
pull back on the band kick the pin free
move the tail of the watch to a diagonal
so it doesn't re-engage in a second hole
and then the final part of the steel
happens at the same time as the visual
special effect moment happens where the
two bills magically change places but
the timing has to be exactly perfect the
moment that the bills switch places all
of the attention shoots back to her
other hand it's possible for the steel
to take place entirely using the thumb
with the person's wrist face up although
this steel is physically easier the mark
could theoretically look down at any
point which makes it more challenging in
that way so the timing here has to be
perfect and the execution surgical but I
do want to give you a gift here's your
gift it is a uh it is a watch does it
look familiar
dude no way dude oh my God you can have
that back thank you level seven the
pants Pockets deal what's your name I'm
John John nice to meet you thank you so
much for being here than so much for of
course I'm going to have you stand maybe
one quick uh uh no no you were good over
there just one little step back that's
perfect beautiful um now uh John this is
a about pickpocketing and uh pickpockets
when they're looking for things to steal
they can either uh see where they are in
a pocket or they can fan you which is
like kind of bumping up against feeling
where things are for example I now know
that you have something in this pocket
is that correct I think it's a wallet
that's probably is that a wallet you
have here awesome okay so you got the
wallet there and then down over here in
that pocket uh what is that is that your
phone that would be the phone yes see
there you go that's the interesting
thing uh most people what they'll do is
they'll have the phone in one of the
pants Pockets um but then if you have
the phone down here the wallet is always
up here that's always what happens I'm
putting the pants pocket steel at level
s for a variety of reasons first of all
the steals happening next to a very
sensitive area of the body pickpocketing
someone in skinny jeans is harder
because it's easier for them to feel it
this involves pinching the pocket which
moves the wallet up for a later steel
all criminal Steels are heavily
environmental and different techniques
are used in different places for one
thing wallet steals from pants Pockets
often happen from the back pocket
otherwise known as the Pratt a method
frequently used for this steel is called
tapping the poke in this case the wallet
is actually pressed up from the bottom
so that it sticks out of the pocket
stall hopping is a term for a pickpocket
stealing someone's wallet while they're
sitting on the toilet we decided that
we're not going to show you footage of
that one for obvious reasons and if you
do want to see footage of that one you
should look inward John I really
appreciate you coming here and letting
me explain uh what Fanning means but
before I go I got a call on my phone but
this dog looks familiar how did you do
that is that your phone that's very much
my phone yeah you can have that back
thank you you didn't feel me take it did
not feel you take it that's a good sign
by the way now is a good time to
acknowledge the fact that our camera
operators and director photography are
actually very very good and talented hey
D yeah is this your credit card jeez God
is this yours uh yeah I I think so yeah
sorry I took that during lunch level
eight the inside jacket pocket I put the
inside jacket pocket at level eight
because of the complexity of the moves
the proximity to the subject's chest and
the level of invasiveness and physical
contact that I have to make with the
mark when I do the steel almost no one
carries big billfold wallets like this
anymore which is a huge bummer because
they are really easy to steal before I
begin I have to determine if someone has
something in this pocket known as the
pit the first thing I always do is look
for the silhouette of an item in the
jacket but this doesn't necessarily work
especially if they're wearing a really
heavyweight jacket in that case I move
on to my other line of defense which is
Fanning well our brains are constantly
getting bombarded by tons of tons of
different signals most people what
they'll do is they'll have the phone in
one of the pants Pockets um but then if
you have the phone down here the wallet
is always up here but evolution has cut
off some portion of those signals as a
survival mechanism if we registered all
of these things we wouldn't be able to
function at all by adding extra signals
and overloading The Mark with Sensations
and thoughts they have so much data to
process that they actually miss the most
important part and the steel flies under
the radar I open the jacket and top the
Poke as I gesture towards the the wallet
I execute the dip using the jacket as
shade and direct his attention to
something else you've gotten this far in
the video which means that you know what
all of that means I mean how cool is
that John uh also one more thing that
wallet that you had in your upper pocket
come on there you go
buddy the final level stealing someone's
neck tie the reason you're here we're
shooting this project about men's
fashion which is why we asked you to
dress up ahead of time and you did not
disappoint thank you this is fantastic I
love the look of everything uh have you
you worn the suit before right yeah I've
broken it a even with the tie as well
yeah yeah it looks really nice um let's
have you take one quick step back just a
small one uh split the difference right
there that's perfect okay great the nice
thing about this fabric is that it looks
like it doesn't hold wrinkles very much
no it doesn't yeah yeah see that's the
thing about when you get those hybrids
is that you can uh the fabric you can
actually uh believe it or not put it in
a suitcase and it still looks great um
and if you look over on this side you
you have a watch on this side right I do
yeah okay and it matches your outfit you
feel like I feel like it beautiful I'm
going to have you turn around so we can
see the full profile Yep looks very very
nice that's great and then uh lastly but
not leastly um I want to comment on the
fact that you've got a bunch of pockets
like down here you have a pocket that
looks very nice and then um of course
over here you have a pocket that's uh
the pants pocket you can put a lot of a
lot of different things over here right
and then over there over there you've
got another one so you look fantastic
man so much yeah it's a it's a great
quality suit I saved the best for last
this is my favorite steel because it
seems completely insane first travel
back to the 1950s when people wore ties
that's actually the hardest part about
this deal is finding someone who's
wearing a tie I suggest finding a
wealthy oil Mogul step one is to
determine how the knot is tied it could
be a simple knot a foreign hand a
windsor Half Windsor Etc I can usually
figure out what type of knot It Is by
looking at it this also tells me which
side of his body I'm going to stand on
so you have to also be able to execute
the steel both right and left-handed
first I have to get my thumb and First
Finger under his collar but above his
jacket I also have to do this as I'm
touching him and sort of moving him
around I move him into place as I
gesture to his neck tie and then I start
sliding the tie out of the knot now
depending on how tight the knot is going
to be is going to determine how hard I'm
going to have to pull really tight knots
are harder to steal but either way I
slowly begin to pull pieces of that tail
out of the knot you'll notice that I I
put my hand on his back I move him into
position I'm talking to him the entire
time constantly splitting his attention
and referencing different things about
the clothing that he's wearing once I
clear the small end of the tie out of
the knot I have to move the large end of
the tie off to his other shoulder so I
gesture to his other side as I grab the
tie and flip it to the back at this
point on stage I like to bring the
person around in a circle asked them to
do a 360 because he has no idea what's
going on but to the audience this is
hilarious next all I have to do is pull
it out of his collar and I am good to go
I started Fanning this guy and
immediately saw and felt that he had
other things in his pockets and since
this was the last level I could not help
myself and I took everything that I
could I've been taking your things
including no is this your beard comb is
that what that is yeah it is what and
this is I believe that is your uh your
uh
of course what else oh yeah and then
your tithe oh my God so you can put oh
yeah and I've got one more thing your
car keys do you drive a Toyota are these
yours those are yeah that's yours okay
and then lastly but not leastly your
phone is this your phone that is that's
not my phone
no whose phone did I
[Music]
take every steel is different based on
the person what they're wearing who they
are what the context is what the
environment is as much as I'd like to
call myself a master of these techniques
I still feel very much like I'm learning
I hope after watching this video you
have a greater understanding for the
world of pickpocketing thanks for
[Music]
watching